[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are we live yeah I didn't hear a
10-second count like your spoon okay we
could just take it from the top because
we're live and everybody understands
that mistakes happen when you're live
what's good everybody and welcome to a
very special episode of what's good
games live on
GameSpot's charity for all live streams
going for several weeks i'm andrea rene
joined by a Christine steamer hello
Brittany Braun Bakker special guest
GameSpot's Callie plaguey is here hey
hey thanks so much for joining us how
are you doing today
thanks for having me I'm excited to be
here but we are excited that you are
here as well and apologies everybody I
know that Rianna Manuel was going to
join us as well and unfortunately she
had some last-minute things come up and
she's not going to be joining our
discussion today but don't worry she'll
be back with us on another episode of
wdg very soon and we have a lot of fun
stuff that we're going to be doing today
including raising money for some
fantastic causes Callie you could tell
us all about that you've got all the
details right can sew or play for all we
are raising money from two different
causes black lives matter and Direct
Relief for Kovan night team you can see
the links in the description
they are bitly link so it'll be fit ly g
esta Ashe BLM and then for Direct Relief
it's bit ly g s slash and it's covered
by the mute icon so I'm gonna hop over
to my little thing and read it out GS -
Kovach so you know we are raising money
for a while and we accept anything at
all every bit counts so I think you
would advance for anyone who donates
will be reading the donations later and
yeah it's it's a great cause
we're really proud to be doing it I mean
we're proud to be part of it we've been
really fortunate to be able to work with
GameSpot for their e3 coverage for the
last couple of years and obviously since
there's no III this year you guys are
doing things differently I think
everybody's doing things a bit
differently and the idea that we get to
still be involved with GameSpot while
also raising money for some fantastic
causes I think is a win win Riley I'm
admittedly my production is great I
don't see us on our twitch channel I see
us on our twitch channel refresh on your
browser page everybody like Brittany and
you're listening to this you're like I
can't see it a good old refresh usually
does the trick you can watch us in a
variety of sources and if you happen to
miss part of the stream today don't
worry we will be uploading this on our
what's good games channel and on our
what's good games podcast apps of course
so if you guys are excited for our
discussion today if you may have missed
it we're going to be talking about games
of the year so far so good so Callie
this is an annual tradition for us here
at what's good games we usually do it
right around now usually the first
weekend of July or the last weekend of
June to kind of take the temperature of
where we're at for the year and 2020 so
far has been a pretty excellent year for
games but I want everybody why'd you
qualified that what for games yeah get
into all the reasons 2020 hasn't been a
good year for a variety of other reasons
there's a reason why we're moving money
for some awesome charities today and
it's because 2020 hasn't been great for
everybody so before we get into our
discussion I want everybody what live
watching live to know that we will be
taking your questions after our
discussion so if you have specific
questions about a game that we discuss
or if you are like I can't believe you
missed this game please let us know you
can drop those questions in the chat and
we have some awesome folks on the
GameSpot side that are going to be
keeping track of those shout out to
chastity we love you chastity
and we kind of narrowed it down to five
key games that we think are good
contenders for game of the year so far
but before we get into that is there any
other housekeeping that I feel like I'm
missing Brittney anything I mean no I
mean we've already talked about or
what's good game summer break that we're
going on I think so yeah good it feels
weird not to have a kajillion things
down the pipe you know I know
we usually start our show with about 15
minutes of announcement yeah sometimes
people are good within sometimes they're
not we have time stamps ladies and
gentlemen for you it's true but you guys
see the links on screen if you are
wondering why you or where you need to
go to donate and we will be calling out
those donations as Kelly mentioned we're
going to take a break in the middle of
our conversation to do some donation
call-outs and then we will finish the
rest of the call-outs at the end of the
show but we're not gonna take a bunch of
breaks in the middle because I'm gonna
keep the conversation flowing and so
without further ado let's go ahead and
get started with games of the year so
far in the year 2020 so the first game
on the list is a sequel ori and the will
of the wisps this is developed by moon
studios and was published on xbox and pc
and it came out early this year and i
was incredibly excited that this game
was made and i loved so much about this
game but before i get into my thoughts
ladies what did you feel about ori and
the will of the wisp smile and nod and
agree with you me too i did not play it
shamefully it's a beautiful game i can
say that there's where's my shame bail I
know I need to get one we'll have it on
set so here's the thing am I the only
one that's played or in the will of
Lewes I played it I have
I made it like half way three quarters
of the way and then subway oh no I lost
patience and like patience is not a
thing I typically have to begin with so
that's always been a struggle for me in
the Ori games but I I really loved them
in general just sometimes my fingers
don't move as fast as I want them to I
mean totally don't blame you for you
know having some issues with the
platforming mechanics so here's the
thing that's great about this game and
first up just look at how beautiful this
game is the art style in this game is
phenomenal I really loved the blind
forest as well and I think that they
really elevated the gameplay and also
the level design in will of the West's
really uh to me a stand out example of a
classic Metroidvania modernized for
audiences that maybe never even heard of
Castlevania or played the original
Metroid's right gamers well against baby
gamers here but what I really love about
this giveaway I think is a game of the
Year contender is because I think that
they really did a great job of giving
people more accessibility options this
time around and they did in the first
game and that makes the game more
approachable for people and the story of
or in everything that already has to
overcome and the story of the villain in
the game and what the villain is going
through and and how they really showed
the other side of that villain story
without you know giving it away if you
guys want to go back and play it I think
is really impactful and really powerful
now that there was a lot of really
emotional moments in this game mixed
with these really some Duns controller
throwing frustrating moments of
platforming mechanics and what I think
was great about this game is that even
if you use a lot of the accessibility
options it doesn't make the game easy it
makes the game easier for people who
need those accessibility options while
still providing challenges because some
of the timing challenges with the jump
mechanics there's no way to get around
them it's like you just have to keep
practicing and practicing and practicing
and I think that's what people look for
in a good platforming game is that
satisfaction of okay I die and have to
do it again I die didn't have to do it
again and then you finally overcome the
challenge
and are able to succeed and I think that
the game really will reward you for
those successes and also encourages you
to do exploration and areas of the map
that you don't necessarily need to go to
but you're like okay maybe I can go see
if there is another upgrade over there
or maybe I want to go look at this other
world design and even just in this short
little piece of gameplay that we see
here which I believe Cali this is from
the review on gamespot comm right it is
it really shows the diversity of the art
environment in the level design and you
get a couple of boss fights here some of
them were super fun and super
challenging and I just can't say enough
about how much I absolutely adored this
game and I'm so glad that this game
exists and if you guys have not taken
the time to check out or in the blind
for us I really just can't can't
convince you more than hopefully you
have right now that you should and while
I wanted to look at this as a game of
the Year contender I fully know that it
doesn't have a chance of winning this
year a lot of big hitters but if we were
going to vote today I think that at
least would deserve a nomination for
everything the team at moon did for this
game I hope at least it's at the very
least I hope it get some art nods
because I think their use of color and
shadow like is really intelligent and
really beautiful so and it's not
something that you see in every game
although it's real - yes absolutely I
thought was really neat about the way
that they did the map is that you can
zoom in and out and actually like will
zoom into the mountainside and then pull
back and give you like a larger view so
you're not just seeing like a grid
overview to help you find your way they
really made it artistic and I feel like
those small touches are sprinkled
throughout this game and really make it
soar and those are the kind of small
details that I think you look for when
you talk about Game of the Year versus
just a game that's really fun to play
and we will be talking about games that
are fun to play of course and we love
those games
I think everybody has different
qualifications for what Game of the Year
means for them and Kelly you do a lot of
reviews you have to think critically
about a lot of games do you have a
specific set of categories or a specific
set of like bullet points you kind of
look for when you're looking for Game of
the Year contenders no I I wouldn't say
I have like a criteria when I when I'm
thinking about Game of the Year I think
a lot about the way the game made me
feel more than anything else and now
something that's not really quantifiable
and I guess it kind of goes up against
what you would expect from reviews cuz
obviously a GameSpot we score our
reviews there is a sense of oh eight or
above could qualify for Game of the Year
kind of thank but for me it's it's more
about like the game make me feel when I
walked away from this game did I admire
about it when did I appreciate about it
and that shifts for me throughout the
year so I really like doing these
conversations in the middle of the year
because last year was really interesting
for me I think I didn't really know what
my game of the year was until I played
disco Elysium and then I was like that's
my game of the year is so good and I
came like you know it just it set itself
apart it gave me a feeling that other
games didn't so I know that's very
abstract but that's that's often what
I'm looking for is is what about this
game captured me and I don't mean like a
game that's like really story heavy and
emotional I just mean like how satisfied
was I by the gameplay and like how wells
that gameplay mesh with the game was
trying to do and that kind of thing so
that's probably helpful that kind of hit
the nail on the head the satisfaction
element I think is a big part of that
right did you want to walk away going
that game is going to stick with me
because it felt so good and I think that
that's a great qualifier I'm thinking
about Orion why I didn't play it I think
it was because we had just got back from
PAX East right this game came out March
so I think we just came back from PAX
East and I remember I was really sick
doctor said OHS bronchitis bronchitis I
think it's probably the Co bit but I
think real bad but I remember it's funny
that Samer was talking about it because
she the way she described ory at one
point was it's very frustration she this
isn't the game where you threw a
controller right this was I threw a
controller and blind forest I didn't
throw more in will of the wisps at least
at the point that I'm at in the game
although I did run into a weird thing
where so I thought I was doing this one
part correctly because it would work
every fourth time so I thought the game
was broken and I was like what is
happening this is busted and it keeps
auto killing me and I feel like it
shouldn't so eventually I probably I
don't know why I didn't think of this
before I just looked it up on YouTube
like I watched someone else do it and I
was like oh my god I'm doing like I'm
not doing the thing that I should be
doing all I have to do is jump on this
[ __ ] thing instead of like instead of
using I was using like the I don't know
what the Ricochet kind of move he has
and I didn't need to be doing that I was
making it more complicated actually than
it was which is funny but I also thought
it was weird that it worked sometimes
and then didn't work other times the
game was trying to tell me no you're
doing this but I wasn't listening I
think it was just I was just not in the
mood for a Metroidvania platformer I was
in the mood for Yakuza and that's
actually when a that's right that's when
I started my Yakuza binge yeah nothing
nothing could stop make superb resident
evil 3 I I think I had Animal Crossing
at the time or he came out and I was
reviewing it so I was like I couldn't
play anything else but also he had just
moved
that's my defense building furniture yes
that was your your frustration element
was building furniture exactly maxed out
there hmm okay well I guess I'll let all
of you off the hook for not playing Ori
in the world the ways I just didn't
finish it but now you got summer break
and there's time so go back and if
you're watching live and you missed it
hopefully even just looking at the
beautiful gameplay has reminded you oh
yeah that thing came out maybe I should
play that game so let's move on then to
our second game since Brittany's so
eloquently almost gave me a transition
there and I'll let you go ahead and
introduce resident evil 3 remake I got a
message from chastity who said she also
thinks our twitch channel is offline
okay well I'm watching I'm watching it
on my computer I sure hope so weird it's
still for me anyway I don't know what's
going on chastity I hear you girl I see
you girl alright let's talk about
president evil 3 so I'm kind of on the
fence with this one in the sense that I
think it was a really great survival
horror game but compared to what
Resident Evil 2 did it just didn't hold
a candle didn't live up to it so
resident evil 3 remake is a remake of
the president's evil 3 game a
PlayStation 1 that came out in 98 or 99
and this game follows Jill Valentine who
is a member of stars and her first
appearance in cheetah's series was in
Resident Evil 1 that was the first game
in the series and then obviously a lot
of people are familiar isn't evil 2
which follows Chris Chris Leon and
Claire and that resident evil 3 dogs
jump in as Jill so I think this game did
a lot of things really great and this is
this is a story of escaping Raccoon City
because shits about to go down who would
have thought in a survival horror game
the city overrun and infested with
zombies thanks Kerry dude hey my baby
all scary dude this is why I didn't play
this game no oh my god what is that
those things were terrifying and
horrible and there's a lot of terrifying
horrible things yeah there's a very good
reason why I didn't play them I have
enough nightmares on my own thank you
very much so
again I want to talk don't want to focus
too on how this game to do some good
things but then of course I have to get
into things I didn't do so well which is
why I don't think it's a true game of
the Year contender especially with this
lineup of games we have coming in the
rest of 2020 and some of the games that
have come out already
so I think it's in a really great job of
expanding the characters of jail Carlos
tyrell mikael these characters who in
the first resident volt bulb and the
original resident evil 3 didn't have
much of a personality they are just very
boring kind of one-liner what the one
dimensional character sides in it and
they have their some chemistry there but
it wasn't anything you know it's write
home about again this is a survival
horror game of late 90s like my daddy
was really yeah you know one was really
expecting like oh my god this is really
good Friday I think they did a great job
with that I think nemesis new design is
terrifying I think it's interesting how
they evolved him as a as a bad guy in
terms of different forms that they give
him and whatnot
the sound design which is no surprise
like it was a residence to you is
phenomenal you know whether or not it's
hearing you know nemesis kind of coming
at you or if it's the creaking of a
floorboard or something falling down an
alley down the street you know there's
always something going on that's keeping
you on edge it's only in those little
safe rooms where I feel like you have
that moment every breathe and even then
if it's not a typical safe room you will
not be safe in there which I found out
with the hard way
there were some interesting new
locations like Jill's apartment there's
the nest - there's a few other buildings
within the city which I think when you
think of a remake you want expansion you
want especially with what they did with
Rose - evil - right you want expand on
all of the things that we loved about
and modernize it and make it appealing
today so this game is currently on a 79
or 80 on Metacritic if you're gonna look
at Resident Evil 2 that's currently at a
91 so therefore there was something
something that was off and I think what
a lot of it has to do with is that some
of you well part of it is a lot of the
iconic locations of this game were cut
unfortunately there's the clock tower at
the cemetery there are [ __ ] Park The
Rock compressed City press and it
I feel like if this game just had a
little bit more of development time it
could have 100% been up there with a
game of the Year contender there is just
I feel like too many little shortcuts
that were taken that unfortunately
worked against it and while I still
think it's a really great game it's just
didn't live up to re - you know I'm not
enjoying this footage I don't know why
not one's neck getting that's not real
high up on my list of things to have
done to move my life I don't think
anyone's gonna disagree with you on that
whatsoever
I love that this game exists I never
thought that I would say that I think
after my amazing experience with
Resident Evil 2 remake it gave me a
renewed sense of interest in Resident
Evil which I know makes Brittany very
happy and proud and I think that Capcom
absolutely deserves you know a pat on
the back for making this game look so
incredible and the atmosphere building
as Bernie was mentioning is really well
done I am with you though bruh debt
while I think that this game absolutely
deserves like a tip of the hat for a job
well done I don't think that it really
has a chance against some of the other
contenders in 2020 to actually win
anything outside of maybe an art award
or a music award or potentially a
character a word but Jill's not new
right like no no but no she's not new
unfortunately yeah like I said the
potential was 100% there it was just I
think some corners were cut and it just
wasn't you know especially since
Capcom's been killing it lately with
their releases I think everyone has very
high expectations and rightfully so and
they just weren't left up to yeah just
not give de Cali how do you feel about
remakes being Game of the Year
contenders or being up for voting or
nominations overall or remasters for
that matter I mean do you think that
yeah they get absolutely equal chance or
you're like well yeah it's interesting
we've had this discussion a lot at
GameSpot especially with the resin
people to remake because I totally agree
that renewed my interest in Resident
Evil I think it's real
special game and was really difficult
trying to determine how you know
quote-unquote fair is it this game has a
kind of a blueprint to work off of
versus a totally new you know fresh take
or a new game or a cool sequel or
whatever it is and we typically don't
allow just regular straight but the
typical plug-and-play remake into that
voting we do however take into account a
game that really transforms the original
in a remarkable way and resen able to
remake early did that so it's a it's a
case-by-case thing and it's really
difficult to quantify again how like
where the line is for R is equals three
we remake I think it's a case of did it
really do enough to invent or recapture
the original I would say probably not I
I agree with everything you guys have
said I think in our review Alessandra
filari
basically said everything that Britt
said - like there's this really good
care yeah seriously it was like a really
good understanding of Resident Evil like
the characterization is great but
there's so much just not magical about
that game and we definitely draw the
line at ports like if it's just a
straight port even if that game is great
no we write that off but a game that's
like really something different
I think resin evil to remake is such a
good example of that and I feel bad to
keep going back to it we're talking
about Resident Evil 3 but I think it
really highlights the difference between
those two remakes in that one really
elevated the original work and one kind
of just did a serviceable job and in
some ways a really good job
like with the the art and the sound
design but just didn't have that in a
sec wah if you will I feel like I'm just
like not making a lot of sense because
to me it's embackment
my language I barely nod I actually mean
it I mean not what you're laying down
for sure that's awesome
I look I just think when you talk about
Resident Evil 2 remake like recapturing
interest in Resident Evil like that is
absolutely what that game did like that
is that is the kind of thing that is
like a game of the year nod worthy that
game really invigorated interest I mean
for me and my little brother is obsessed
with Resident Evil he's played all of
them like I've watched him play a bunch
of those games and I had definitely just
kind of like my interest have really
waned and to remake really recaptured
that and and I do like the scares I
I do like zombie game as we will talk
about later but um just it's just
missing a piece and it's what you know
what I when I edit reviews sometimes
writers will talk about like well this
game like should have this thing and I'm
like wait can't really fault a game for
what it doesn't have you really need to
evaluate what's there um but when you're
talking about Game of the Year it's a
little different because it is really
about like a magical feeling like game
being above other a basic level yeah I'm
just rambling at this point especially
when you know you're a lifelong fan of a
franchise like you know I haven't played
Resident Evil since I was so 8 which I
don't remember commend eight-year-olds
play that game please don't give me
nightmares for many years but when you
see it you see the potential that could
have been there and it is a critical eye
that even though the Resident Evil is
probably when I talk three favorite
favorite franchises it's it was missing
that magic and I think a lot of that had
to do with it when you look at Resident
Evil 2 look at all the different
scenarios you could play right Leon and
Claire and Capcom has built that story
and made it intertwine and granted some
of the puzzles were slightly different
some of the objects were placed
differently but the fact that they took
that care to make that happen for that
apparent that wasn't the original but
with resident evil 3 like that wasn't a
priority that wasn't a thing that needed
to be done but
instead of taking that and maybe saying
okay well we're not gonna do that cool
feature we're gonna do something
different with it they really didn't and
they even reuse the Raccoon City Police
Department it's a big chunk of that game
when you're playing as Carlos like
that's a reused asset you know so you
can tell that like they were able to
kind of like slip by a little bit and
some of the story now Andrea I know
you've played Resident Evil 2 but I feel
like maybe it's just because I'm a
serious
I feel like resident evil 3 it was
probably a little confusing you're
probably wondering who the heck is this
Brad guy why is Jill in her apartment
and she's waiting to why she under house
arrest I don't know if any of that even
thought to cross your mind because I
know you're just playing it casually I
think that it probably didn't Donna Me's
and some of those narrative things cuz
you and you were like hand-holding me
during that playthrough for the most
part right and so you were able to tell
me everything in real time which I
really loved and so I think I can't even
evaluate it as somebody who'd be
approaching our III having never played
it because I didn't get to have that
experience I had the best re tutor by my
side through that whole streaming
experience so but I'm with you I think
that we're all in agreement that this
game was great and they did a lot of
things well but it didn't quite hit the
genes-- a qua magic that re to remake
had last year I obviously have no
opinion about this cuz I didn't finish
either game but it you're tough your
conversations have been reminding me of
how I felt back in the day with fable 2
versus table 3 and so I kept Babel two
just had this bit of magic to it where I
played that game for like hundreds of
hours and then fable 3 came out and I
played it and it was technically fine
right like it technically checked a lot
of boxes that it needed to check but
there was just something about it that
was kind of off and it was really hard
to pinpoint what that specifically was
and so it kind of feels like when you
guys are talking about it it's a little
bit of that yeah absolutely
that makes sense lot of discussion so
our third nominee for a game of the year
so far
it's Animal Crossing New Horizons
and we got ever my entire life I know
I'm happen and the funniest part to me
is that yeah out of all of us on the
crew you are the one who's still the
most invested in this game and I was
like you shouldn't bother playing it you
won't like it that's a timer said to me
my husband said it to me Brittany's like
I don't know you might like it
I told you to give it a shot I was like
just give it's relaxing you know you
still turnips I don't know but now that
million-dollar bail loan you got though
was probably the thing that actually
kept you going I think I've gotten that
you would have you would have left 100%
agree and I disagree I've said that over
and over again shout it again to Maria
for all those threatening me into plane
by saying I'm okay with boom you're
gonna play and you're gonna play for at
least 60 days and I'm gonna give you a
million bells to do it and I was like
okay I'm ready I'll do it I'll commit so
she gave me a million bells in my second
week of playing and boy oh boy just
getting a lot of money up front really
changed the experience for the better
what would I pack every game that I play
of the sims boys just like cash cash
give me okay I think I don't obviously
want to judge the game based on that
because there are clearly millions of
people who played without getting a
million Bell loan upfront and love it
and are having a great time like that
one percenter of grunts that are like
working at McDonald's he started out
like Animal Crossing nepotism yep except
she's not related to me but that's okay
but Thank You Maria I appreciate that I
tried to give it back to her and now
she's like I'm too rich for your like I
don't even need the million I've got I
feel yeah she's like your um your measly
1 million bail loan I don't need that
money back get out of here and I was
like okay fine I'll keep it looks you
know I finally paid off Tom Nook and I
was like I don't want those hanging over
my head
but yeah get out of debt I'm so Callie
animals that's the animal crossing story
you've been playing animal crossing oh
yeah I play every single day and I got
the game on February 28th it's like
every single day um but I mean I I love
Animal Crossing I played every single
animal crossing game except for the n64
one that was Japan only and um I played
I think it was wild world I played every
day for two years so that's commitment
level crossing to me is a lifestyle it
is a surface game it is my like I played
destiny but I was gonna say it's my
destiny like I just like I I go back
every day for like a new thing and I
have I have these like mini goals for
myself and I did review it I adore it
and I really had loved a new leaf I did
it did think that I could love an Animal
Crossing game more than I loved a new
leaf and I was so nervous about new
horizons when they talked about the
crafting I was like this is gonna suck
I'm not gonna like this like it's not a
survival game I don't know why they're
making me craft stuff and I so I was
really resistant to it and I said I
think it's it's a lot it's a lot to deal
with and I was like you're you mean
you're gonna make me collect a bunch of
materials every day but found that the
editions work their way into the key
gameplay loop of Animal Crossing so
brilliantly and one of the examples I
used in my review was shaking trees
early on in the game shaking trees is
something you can do to make money
pretty easily because there's five wasps
per day I think a thousand bells and
then two furniture items from shaking
trees and shaking trees also gives you
wigs or tree branches to use in crafting
so it's like gathering a crafting
material but you're accomplishing a goal
you would have been trying to accomplish
in a previous Animal Crossing game it
doesn't feel like there's another just
another chore throwing it
it feels really smartly woven into the
gameplay loop that I already liked and I
think that terraforming terraforming was
another thing that scared the [ __ ] out
of me I was like I'm gonna ruin my whole
island I'm not I'm not good at this I
can't believe it this game is about
making you like go to a strange town and
like blend did not become like a God in
the town but actually really love the
customization that's what's keeping me
playing every day I'm like okay I'm
gonna go around my Island I'm gonna see
okay this is where I want to move the
museum so in order to do that I have to
move this person's house and then I'll
put my neighborhood over here and I have
this whole like 10-year plan for my
eyelid it really is keeping me invested
and I I know that people Animal Crossing
fans complain about like the lack of
content but I I think that the rollout
of events and stuff has been really
smart because it would be really
overwhelming if you had art right from
the get-go when you also have
terraforming and crafting and all these
other features to deal with
I think the slow rollout of events has
actually helped make it a little more
digestible the power players don't care
they're like I've already gotten a
five-star Island I paid off my loan I
don't have enough to do but I think for
the average player it's a really good
way to like parse out those those big
tasks and I just love it and I I think
you said it earlier Andrea like who
would never think to say an animal
crossing game is game of the year
material the way this has captured so
many people I do think that Ovid has had
an effect on that people being stuck
inside meeting something bright and
happy I do think that what this game is
at its core is really strong and I think
the like the quarantine effect on it is
I don't say that to undermine what what
Animal Crossing New Horizons has done
because I really do think it's it's such
a well-done creative sandbox of a game
and that's my schpeel you hit on so many
great points and I think that the
pandemic is absolutely contributing to
how many people are getting into Animal
Crossing including myself because if I
was traveling the way that I normally
would be and if we had a traditional III
I definitely would not be hitting my
rocks and digging up my fossils every
day like a good and I really love about
you know some of the thoughts that you
mentioned was this idea of you know
parsing it out so when I was on animal
talking with the West Kadena's crew we
heard from animal talking of course as
Garry widows animal crossing show that
is on twitch and if you guys have not
checked it out it's phenomenal I mean
he's getting people like Shaggy stinging
like the blood t-pain all kinds of
people obviously what's good games is
right up there with those but tim
schafer was on our episode and not only
is tim a lovely person shadowed tim
schafer but he said something that stuck
with me that I've talked about on our
show about animal crossing that he
thought was poignant of the message that
it's okay to slow down that you don't
need to get everything all at once and
that life is never going to allow you to
have everything you want the moment that
you want it that you are gonna have to
work for some things and it's gonna take
time is you can't just always throw
money at problems and you got hey listen
I try I'm like okay nook is on how many
bills do I need but I think that it's a
good overall message of animal crossing
that took me a long time to learn
because at the beginning I like
everybody was like I this game isn't
moving fast enough I have time to play
the game right now I'm mad that the game
isn't letting me do more and it's taken
me months of playing the game now to
fully kind of understand what you said
about it's too much to digest all at
once if the game is just like okay
here's all the stuff you can do and I
think that that is a really different
way to play and sometimes it frustrates
me not gonna lie there's a lot of DIYs
that I wish I could get but but I think
overall I really appreciate that
sentiment and there's something that has
forced
like stop and be a little bit more
patient than I normally am I think that
one reason why I stopped playing was I
felt like I couldn't this is the only
part that really bothered me obviously
there are some quality of life issues
with the menu system and UI but was more
that I felt like I couldn't get a good
read on exactly how to kick people off
my island that was I don't want this
person here I want another one
I want another villager but I don't know
how to actually make you leave and there
doesn't seem to be anything online looks
like a surefire way and so I've just
kind of like stopped logging in because
I didn't want to go say hi to everybody
I do feel fortunate that I'm kind of
lucked out that I don't have get one I
don't really have a villager that I
really hate there is one villager that I
inherited from Joey Noel
that's right kind of funny is Joe Noel
who is this pig named Kevin not Joey the
villager Joey's a wonderful person I
would never be Joey off my Island but
there's this like he's he's got like
tiger stripes but he's got a pig it's
weird you see like a boar but he he
wants to be the bouncer of cloud wine
which is the name of my island he like
as always are out doing patrols he's
like I saw somebody suspicious oh
they're just your friend you invited
over well then never mind I was like
don't come down yeah chill out Kevin
house and terraform like a thing of
water around him so he can't ever get
out again the moat method wait okay so
tell us about the moat method I need to
know what is this oh you trap them house
and then eventually they get upset can
you people off your Island is actually
so much more difficult in this game
because they made it like they added a
layer of like in in previous Animal
Crossing games like your villagers could
just move out like if you didn't play
for a week like you would return and
your villager will be gone
they don't do that in this
like they have to get your permission so
it's harder to get rid of people but if
you really hate someone you don't want
to interact with them you can put a moat
around their house and then they can
never leave you can do that I the other
thing about this game that was kind of
added to my appreciation of it I guess I
worked on a lot of the guides so I did
have I broke guides about like how to
invite amiibo villagers and how to kick
off people FIBO kick kicking out it's
like the surefire way to kick somebody
out of your island um it's like
automatic and I did a lot of that stuff
so I got really deep into the systems of
the game your guide work um
Shh I don't know that's if like a weary
meadow has an amiibo right there's only
a certain amount
hey there's amiibo cards for everybody
except for payment and like like the
really popular cat that everybody loves
and is kind of creepy about I've got
Raymond
and I didn't realize right even now I
didn't realize he was so popular until
like friends was like yo you could sell
him for so many bells million oh my god
really
millions of bells on jazz on I so I got
really into new Kazan and I am very
active I that's how I've gotten like all
the DIYs that I didn't get new Kazan is
this like other metal air I get really I
just I love Animal Crossing so much but
yeah you could sell you could sell
Rayman for Life Bank
I like Raymond oh yeah Andrea you could
sell me for millions of dollars what to
start calling me crisp like Raymond does
he calls me crisp i crisp I got you I
got you
the thing name the animal crossing and
I've talked about this so I won't be the
dead horse here it's just like I
understand the point of relaxation some
of my favorite games of all time or the
farming Sims let me just water my crops
my cows and give eggs to people they'll
like me but there is just not enough
sense of direction I don't get off on
the decorating like Andrea does I don't
it doesn't like do anything for me so
with the lack of direction and I think
for me just I like to play at night
before bed but everyone's full good
sleepin don't know I can't do much of
anything it felt like really good night
you can make money make your money
tarantula hunting at night that's what
exactly what I want to do right before
bed yeah I've always been intrigued by a
lacrosse in and I thought for sure this
would be the one that hooked me and it
did for a while but then I just then you
fell off in any when you went back you
had terrible bedhead yeah oh yeah that's
right I did yeah I was like what is she
talking about I'm just gonna smile and
nod but yeah when I finally hopped back
in to do animal talking with the with
the lady is my poor little villager woke
up and her hair is all messed up there's
like a cockroach in my house
I was like oh sorry - the rules it was a
book I just assumed you as a cockroach
yeah I think skittering along the ground
you don't sleep for a while your house
gets infested oh my gosh I mean yeah I'm
like oh no if I go back in what am I
gonna find I did log back in after like
a week and a half or so like even like a
month ago and I as soon as I watch out
of my house cuz it was evening a
tarantula ran up and bit me and I felt
it was like wow thanks animal crossing
no that's your that's your warning to to
not abandon your Island I mean I guess
but the tarantulas will come after you
okay scorpions now oh sorry Scorpio yet
actual eyes are old news now at
scorpions oh so they change yeah change
with the seasons come on tarantulas are
six months the year and the scorpions of
the other six month so it's tarantulas
Australian stuff right now okay we have
Australian viewers you guys have
tarantula we gotta take a ship on down
there
I mean when we were first talked about
the tarantulas dimer got a low-key upset
that they ran in bit people because
steamer Kali you might not know this
used to be a professional spider handler
I was a reptile writer we had a spider
the spider was just part of the crew
[Laughter]
transmitted using yeah I was like the
tarantulas not gonna run at you and like
attack you it's going to run away from
you of anything okay Alexa I was
backflip off the earth if a tarantula
charged me to try to bite me really
fragile like really fragile if you
kicked them they would probably just die
like you would be fine video games just
aren't realistic I mean the game where
you have a bunch of anthropomorphic
animals walking around talking shame
this game you can have a frog neighbor
and then go catch a frog so yeah now
we're weird that was definitely weird I
heard when Henry he's great he sings I
love it great he tried to leave my
island was knows like Henry no house is
so fashionable yes
gum all that iron cute I went I sold all
the stuff that was outside of those
houses it's like you know you build the
house and it's like I want these things
outside like alright fine
oh and then they all moved in and I was
like I don't even really like you that
much I'm taking your stuff and I'm
selling it say anything and they still
live there I mean as far as I know they
haven't asked to leave I haven't logged
in do your original villagers ever ask
to leave or is it just like the new ones
that come in anybody can ask to leave I
I follow some data miners and I guess
the way it works is like there's a cycle
of like how many days has to pass after
somebody leaves before another person
will ask to leave and it factors include
like whether you say yes or no and who
it is and so one method people do is
there's a lot of soft reset and you can
do two like if somebody asks you to
leave and it's not the person you want
to leave you can reset and walk
until the one you want leave that it's a
pain in the ass if you're not invested
don't do it but I these are the things
that I care about and I all the
Twitter's right but yeah yeah I mean I
there's a lot of people that care about
it they're like there's like so many
threads about people trying to get
specific villagers on their Island and
I'm like as long as they're nice I don't
really care I think I saw Justine play
for like 24 hours to get Raymond the one
you have oh really yeah hmm I was like
dedication but went apeshit for Raymond
I the biggest thing about Raymond is
because he doesn't have an amiibo card
like that's the only way you can get him
is by buying him from somebody for like
real money or hunting for like a full
day I I'm that's where I draw the line
I'm not doing that yeah well - I don't
play every day for a year I'm not doing
that
I play for 24 hour period so in
conclusion I love the game I'm glad we
are gonna take a quick break to do some
charity call oz don't forget you guys we
are raising money for some great causes
but before we do that I do want to ask
you one final question
Kellie about animal crossing as an
animal crossing diehard how do you feel
about time travel I don't do it I don't
care about it personally I get stressed
out because I like the day in my game to
match the day in real life I found that
it helps me keep track of the days in
Zdenek world so sad but true if you want
to time travel it's fine careful of I
turnips
hey I just can't do it
[Laughter]
mmm I've thought about experimenting
with time travel but some of the girls
that are in the animal crossing discs or
that I'm in have spoken out very much
like we don't time travel all the time
she's like in December right now what
why would you why what's the key benefit
so the key benefit the time traveling is
you get access to certain items and
recipes that are only available
seasonally okay but when we're crossing
team also only reveals specific types of
seasonal stuff the day that it launches
so some stuff you can get through time
traveling and other stuff you cannot yes
their releases like I don't think that
stuff is pre-built into the game or
maybe it is yeah like the seasonal like
items and recipes are but the events
aren't so I don't think there's like a
whatever the equivalent of Christmas is
an animal pressing I forget it's like
treating or something um that's not in
the game there's no like Halloween in
the game yet but you can go to fall and
like mushroom items are really cute
everybody's really about the mushroom
items they're like you I kind of wanna
get some mushroom items from nikka's on
to build a little allison Wendling and
then have bad hat or tea party is
somewhere on my island mogul look is on
it's an external website where people
can advertise DIYs or items they have
and you connect via discord or you
communicate like via DM where you
exchange bells and visit each other's
islands to do like a barter system for
four items it's it's all fan-made and
it's really sophisticated and like they
do a lot to make sure like somebody
can't come and like steal all your fruit
or like ruin your Island
people are like I was telling let's talk
about this on GameSpot after dark
podcast like it's a little bit of like
social media interaction I have it kind
of like a social media platform people
can review you and DM different people
if they have an item that you want and
everybody's super respectful like people
stay right at your Airport nobody like
wanders and there's like this kind of
unspoken etiquette about how to trade
and it's so positive I just I need it
it's like a little bit of positivity
it's I would highly recommend it if
you're into animal
saying if you're not it's just going to
be intimidating probably probably not
words your time but I could go on and on
and on about animal crossing but we have
some other big games that we want to
talk about in our discussion so we're
going to get to those in just a second
but I think would be a good time Callie
to check in on how we're doing with
fundraising I know it's a little bit
different with our discussion that we're
not able to to pump the the donations
like some of the gameplay streams have
but we hope that you guys are you know
looking at all of the information and if
you can't donate do one step that you
can do which is educate yourself about
what's happening with the pandemic and
also what's happening with black lives
matters both things are very important
and deserve your time and attention so I
don't know how you want to maybe check
in it doesn't work we've moved the
needle too much yet seeing a little bit
so I'll just check in because I have
those donations feeds like we said at
the top of the show we have two
different causes like you said also uh
black lives matter and directly fork
over nineteen so I'll start with a black
lives matter feed and see if we have any
new donations I will probably butcher
your name and of course it logged me out
I think I still have the password copy
and all right well I'm will them for a
couple of minutes while everything good
to go like I surprised it was that quick
so we've got a couple donations and
they're all very generous so I'll read
them out now this is all for black lives
matter
again you can donate to black lives
matter with bit ly /gs - BL on first one
we have is a $50 donation from Maria F
SAR thank you so much that's incredibly
generous the other thing about the black
lives matter of donations don't have
messages but the dreck relief ones well
so if you meant to leave a message I'm
sorry because I can't see them so thank
you Maria
we have a ten dollar donation from
Noah's ich bowl
thank you I'm so sorry about these names
I also have a hair done listen we're
known for butchery names on our show
it's true it right in it's a thing we
have a $25 donation from Nick Kelly
thank you so much Nick
and finally a $50 donation from a Justin
boshi thank you so much everybody
it is wonderful so generous and of
course you don't have to be donating
huge amounts if you can donate anything
at all we very much appreciate it and
like Andrea said definitely educate
yourself you know not everybody can
terminate them but that's something you
can do all right I'm going down for
there's a lot actually of Direct Relief
donations and I see one from friend Joey
Noel so I'll start with hers $10 from
Joey
Greg is kind of okay I guess we actually
have a lot of messages about Greg
thinking with a $25 donation way to
shoot the guy on the ground oh wait is
this from yesterday maybe it is it
probably is yeah I do want to read the
Greg there's a lot of Greg messages that
I find very interesting but shout out to
Joey if you if we read that yesterday
shout out to Joey again so probably
there's probably backlog messages we got
one from Chris that's ten dollars with
Greg doesn't suck people are a little
confused yesterday our friends that kind
of funny played with Lucy in some war
zone and I particularly liked the clip
that they pulled out of them saying his
singing come back it was pretty bad it
was kind of funny
see what I did there I did I'll read
some new ones that come in so we have a
$50 donation from Trevor Starkey you all
Rock thanks Trevor you so much we have
another $50 donation from Foshee 15 I
think that that person also donate to
black lives matter so thank you so much
for the double donation in our community
fo she gives our community gifts subs
all the time and as a supporter of ours
on patreon and is all around an awesome
generous person awesome thank you again
oh we got Wow
a $100 donation from Project Toro oh
yeah credible thank you so much then I
just want to shout out the most recent
donation from anonymous who definitely
heard me say that every little bit
counts of $1 donation from anonymous
thank you and I'd like legitimately want
to shout that out because like I said
any little bit counts anything you can
give so thank you so much absolutely and
just to reiterate we'll probably read
more donations at the end of the show so
if you are able to continue to donate
you can find the links below our
wonderful faces and yeah thank you so
much to everybody who has been donating
to both of these fantastic causes as
Kelly mentioned we will be reading more
donations once we're done with our
discussion and we will be taking your
questions I know chastity is calling for
questions in the chat on the gamespot
channel and we'll be looking for
questions in the West good games channel
because we are hosting on Twitch and I
see that some of our subscribers have
found our new emotes which is great and
we're gonna go ahead and continue on
with our discussion on games of the year
so far because these next two games are
probably going to be a lot of discussion
the first one is one that I never
thought that I would be talking about is
one of my favorite games of the year
it's Final Fantasy 7 remake Brittany you
want to set this one up for us yeah 7
remake is
make more of a reinvention of Final
Fantasy 7
so it's interesting about what they did
with this remake I like to call a
reinvention but it's technically a
remake is they took the first five or so
hours of the game which take place in
Midgar and they turned it into a 40 well
my playthrough was 40 hours into a 40
hour game and I would say more or less
than the reviews on us have been
incredibly positive but there are some
concerns from people regarding the
padding of the game some people felt
like it was it was too much there's too
much fluff too much unnecessary side
quests or fetch quests if you will in
between the main plot points but I would
say for the most part people are they're
really feeling it including one Andrea
Renee including one Christine Samer
including myself Callie did you play
this I didn't finish it because I did
have to move on a lot of fun new cycle
goes I know review cycle is unrelenting
but I will say I think that it's
definitely an example of what we talked
about earlier of a remake that does more
that earns its spot in the current year
it makes it contemporary and makes it
eligible for a discussion during like a
2028 game of the year discussion I was
just blown away by what they did with
this game and we'd been seeing this for
a couple of years at press events from
Square Enix Japan and really the
animation I think stood out first and
foremost of people who are fans of the
original it's like wow they took these
iconic Final Fantasy characters and
reinvented them with all new character
models but still really paying homage to
their original art and I think that
that's something that's not easy to do
and they absolutely deserve a pen on the
back for a job well done like I just
kept stopping in awe during all of the
cutscenes of this game and even the
gameplay which we're seeing here looked
fantastic and that's really difficult to
do and I think that we're really seeing
a lot of Studios push the envelope with
what's being done with photo realism and
I think that
games like Final Fantasy 7 that are
clearly fantasy based really need to you
know kind of shoot that gap between
looking to video game II and looking
photo-realistic and I think that Final
Fantasy 7 remake absolutely crushed it
and I'm now I'm distracted watching the
games because I'm just remembering and
like I think touching off a little bit
of what you said about the animation of
them all I really liked how it
especially in combat they not only
nailed the look of them you know as
they're walking around the world but
they they all felt different in combat
so you know Barret feels very heavy when
you're running around with him eros
feels like we beat things up so like
it's it's I think it was really nice to
see that they all not only visually
looks different but also played very
different and that gives you a little
bit more variety if you were like I've
killed this because they yeah those
things for annoying just like so many of
them all over the place when you're
hacking through all these these levels
eventually you kind of like want to mix
it up you get to hop around everybody
else it's such a rewarding combat combat
system to this once you really get it
down you feel like such a badass
especially when you're like doing all
this stuff and then you push oh I don't
know what the tactical menu is to bring
it up when things slow down in their mid
motion and you execute all these other
commands and I was really impressed with
the combat system and I really liked it
when I first played this at e3 God was
at 20 18 I think it was 20 18 I just
remember being like it's it looks
complicated I think if you don't know
what's going on but once you get the
hang of it
I think it's really intuitive and I
think it's a great system it's a way to
reinvent the combat of the original
Final Fantasy 7 which was purely
turn-based at that time it's also worth
noting that there is a mode in here that
you can't have more turn-based combat if
you wanted to but this is the standard
mode that we're watching yes I really
found it such a nice balance and I know
that some people who are diehard
turn-based fans and it didn't really
like how actually it felt but I think
because of how well they did the
third-person combat it brought someone
like me who is not a fan of turn-based
at all in
the mix and I actually enjoyed some of
the more turn-based moments cuz I think
that they really had this nice hybrid
which is so hard to nail we've seen a
couple other games attempt to do these
like real-time strategy elements mixed
in with combat I think another game that
did it really successfully was Dragon
Age Inquisition even though not a lot of
people used that mode in in Dragon Age
but I think what I really loved about
this is that I felt like each of the
individual characters really felt unique
in their combat play styles along with
combining what the items were now I did
say that I thought it was a little bit
challenging to learn what all these
items were if you're unfamiliar with
Final Fantasy 7 naming conventions
obtuse and I eventually found Phoenix
down I mean wouldn't you think about it
it makes sense but the game doesn't
really handhold you through how to use
any of these things you really have to
dig into text menus to figure out that
part of it which I didn't particularly
like but I didn't care enough for it to
bother me because the gameplay was still
so much fun and having no context for
the story whatsoever I thought that the
story had a really great beginning
middle and end and it did kind of the
very very end of the game which yeah we
won't talk about but I think overall I
never expected to be so hooked on what
was happening in this game that I was up
until like 2 or 3 o'clock in the morning
every night that I played this game cuz
I just could not put it down yeah I like
the I do think it's interesting about
the ending because obviously we won't
talk about what it is but I was
definitely like I understand it I
understand it I understand it I
understand it what the [ __ ] just
happened but then we did talk about it
often I wish again what I won't see what
we did but when we when you and I
discussed Britney and like we're really
diving into very spoilery territory on
what it all means and like how it all
plays out it was like oh actually that's
really cool like that wouldn't it
doesn't require you to go and look
it up on the internet basically or go
find somebody to talk to with it that's
a little bit more knowledgeable than you
but it is something that even as
somebody who is not super into final
fantasy I really appreciated once I
understood a little bit more context
behind what was going on and if you did
understand that context of what was
going on it was one of the most holy
Athene [ __ ] aha moments I think I've
ever had I was playing a game and I just
started yelling very loud but know that
and I mean also just want to talk about
the music too in this game I think the
music it just complements the game from
so many directions and it's just some of
the best I mean it was already so good
the way it was in the original game but
they took it and they're like oh no
we're gonna make it better and you're
saying yourself I don't know about that
and like oh just you watch just you sit
down and then think freaking did it the
gate the oh they're one of the songs
it's called like the underside of the
pizza or something I don't know it's
actually I wonder why we got it I don't
know it's something like that steel Pete
there's a pizza I lean dogs with pizzas
in there but like that was one of the
best tracks as soon as that kicked in I
was like holy [ __ ] when you hear a very
iconic boss team that was one of the
most again like amazing moments I think
in a boss in during a boss fight that
either experienced and it's just so
incredibly exciting what they did with
it the fact that they're able to expand
on all these old characters like with
the original resident evil three that
were so one-sided I felt like so
one-dimensional you know you got Jesse
and biggs and wedge and granite they had
some interesting personality little
clips in quotes but they didn't last
very long in that game and the original
one they were around you know like i
said meet max of a couple hours where
you really it's like chat with them and
interact with them and then they're gone
but in this one they really flesh them
out and i enjoyed and appreciated all
the extra side content that some critics
I think didn't like because I feel like
otherwise how else are we gonna get to
know these characters as they are like
what are they like outside of avalanche
and that was a really interesting
perspective that we're able to get and I
just have kind of continued on that
sense a man I think that that was what
really defines this game as being such
an amazing piece of work in the sense
that this is a
a full remake right like you had
mentioned Britney that people were
complaining diehards were complaining
there was too much filler and I would
say I didn't think that there was too
much filler I think that there was just
the appropriate amount for what we got
from the bill the built out systems in
the world for example take woolmarket
and the whole level around wall market
and how if you didn't have those little
sidequest doing like the squat contest
or going you know back to the brothel
and all the little things that you can
do you wouldn't get to see the amount of
love and care that got put into building
out wall market right all of the nooks
and crannies and all of the world
building and the art direction and the
the voices of the NPC's all interacting
that really made that section of the
game feel particularly alive whether
there were of course like we could
nitpick about some of the side quests
but I think that I never and never once
crossed my mind wow this feels so
annoying I don't want to do this I felt
like this gives me an opportunity to go
explore a section of the world that I'm
probably never going to see if I just
mainline the story I'm gonna miss out on
the world building that was done in this
game and I think that that is maybe
sometimes lost on people when they're
trying to like oh I only want to play
this game for X amount of hours and it's
like but you're missing it somebody put
a lot of love into this little corner of
the game and I really enjoyed taking the
time to explore those moments yeah I
don't for me either I don't think it
felt like too much I completed every
side quests in the game and I was like
they could have technically added more
they didn't need to obviously but for me
it was like the right amount of filler
if you will I thought yeah kept me
satisfied kept me intrigued yeah I think
it's just so remarkable to that this
game was in development for so long and
generally when that happens it's kind of
a big red flag right like what what are
you really expecting out of it but the
fact that they just execute it in my
mind darn near perfectly as perfect as a
video game can get it's just insane
so definitely this and I think one of
the other games we're gonna talk about
right now is definitely top contender so
far for 2020 Oh daddy Sephiroth I'm
right honestly like I thought this game
had such a great ending with everything
that happened you know in the final in
the final chapter which I mean it did
feel like the longest chapter I've ever
played but I was like before that very
very very final scene I was like oh this
could just have been this could just
have been a game and then when Brittany
is going into detail about what else is
to come in Final Fantasy 7 I was like
how are they going to make this into
just one more episode wait until we die
when I'm 80 years old
they'd all still be coming out with just
started mocap for part 2 I'm hoping the
dev cycles will be shorter now that they
have like hopefully the engine down a
lot of the systems are built it should
knock on wood make it go slightly faster
but we'll see it does give me plenty of
time to play I think I'm gonna take kind
of like this summer lull create we're
not a lot of stuff comes out especially
but kind of the delays that we've seen
I'm gonna take that time to play it my
boyfriend keeps telling me like you will
love it like you have to just like just
dedicate time to it and so I'm really
excited it we did give it a 10 out of 10
which is a rare score we gave a couple
games a 10 out of 10 in a short span but
it is a rare score for GameSpot and for
the US that's essential and so me that's
like I have to play it it's something
that you know my colleagues deem
essential and I think that absolutely
just guarantees it a spot when we're
talking about Game of the Year like
that's gonna be in our talk so I'm very
excited here you guys talk about ocean
wanna play like just like play right
after this do it I'm like I've never
thought that I would contemplate going
back and playing this game again but who
knows maybe I maybe I will maybe I'll
just go back to wall market and do do
the squat contest from now until the end
of that I really just want to play the
honey bee in scene over and over again
I kind of botched that that dance scene
where you yo in poor Aerith she was
looking she's like oh I know it suck
though because I wanted to just watch
cloud move I didn't wanna have to you
know follow the stupid little thing that
was moving around I thought it was a
cute mechanic though and also just want
to give shout out to that scene because
the original Final Fantasy 7 that hold
on her knee was matching the honeybee
and the whole thing was you know
problematic good good word for it and
it's today's world like just so uh not
the way they handled it though just went
was incredibly great I think it was a
wonderful message that they sent and
they executed it that was also like that
was always one of the things right when
I do remake this game how are they gonna
treat that scene how are they gonna what
are they gonna do and although I did see
and like I said you just needed a foul
mode as what you wanted right at what a
freestyle mode yeah absolutely I could
have done like the Macarena on the stage
just cloud that I've been good oh my
gosh cloud doing the chicken dance I
feel like I written best needs to happen
trying to I I feel like I watch that
yeah it would be great at talking you
what I feel like Andre I would be great
at Turkey no of course yeah oh yeah that
like no question mm-hmm just built into
his blood well now that we have finished
gushing about Final Fantasy 7 remake one
of our favorite games of the year I
think it's time to talk about the game
that everybody's talking about and we
are going to do our best
a spoiler free as possible there will
probably be some very mild or light
spoilers as we talk about characters and
scene so if you have not yet played The
Last of Us part two which is the fifth
game on our games of the year so far
contender list you may want to just
pause or join us in about 15 to 20
minutes for our Q&A session
and otherwise we'll keep it as like I
said a spoiler free as possible but if
you haven't played yet you're trying to
go in blind first off congratulations if
you've made it this far and not seen
anything and we will be doing a full
spoiler cast for what's good games which
will be our episode coming out this
Friday so if you want to get into the
nitty gritty look for that but we're not
gonna do that here so Callie have you
finished the last of us part two I have
I reviewed it and I did two different
versions of the same review of one with
no spoilers and one with spoilers so I
have really done some deep dives into it
we also have a spoiler cast it's it was
occupying a lot of my mental energy hmm
I didn't know you read a spoiler review
I'm gonna have to go check that out
before we do our our recording later
I've been trying to go around and read
more reviews but I missed that one
it was a kind of experiment we've never
done anything like that and I thought
that of any game this one warranted
especially with the embargo restrictions
I'm sure you're all familiar with oh yes
your interest very limiting and so I
figured you know some people are gonna
want an opinion on this game that has no
spoilers and I'm going to fulfill that
need with this spoiler free review but
for people who want to process it it's
it's the game it's kind of game you
really need to process and parse and
think about and that was my
justification and it actually paid off
people I didn't think people would click
on a spoiler review but they didn't so
that was the thinking there but odd and
that that game like haunted me like a
full week after I finished it I couldn't
even like do anything so in a good way
or in a bad way but I guess overall I
would say good like I think it's a very
heavy kind of miserable sort of game but
you know I gave it an 8 and my
justification for that was I think it is
really just a fantastic character study
I really
but I dog did with all of the women in
this game I mean it's not just the women
that are good characters but I think
that you really get to see how Lee has
been affected by Joel's actions in the
first last of us and you know when
people asked like was this was a sequel
necessary the original Last of Us I you
know maybe before I play this game I
would tell you I don't think so but I
loved seeing ramifications and
consequences of Joel's actions and the
exploration of that in this game that's
ultimately why I landed on I'm liking it
it's it's you know it was really hard to
play I think I played like three hours a
day because I did have a lot of time
with it before the review which was
awesome I don't often get that much time
with a game when I'm reviewing it and
that helps so much because I really
couldn't play a lot at a time it's it
gave me nightmares not and I'm scared
wait just and then like the just the
weight of the person that's happening
and the stress and some tense so it was
hard to say at first if I liked it I I
had to think about it before I can
really determine what I felt
I know exactly that feeling and the
longer I sit with my feelings on it the
more that I'm able to fully understand
how I feel so when we talked about the
game so steamer got the advance copy for
what's good games and gave her full
thoughts on the game oh so spoiler-free
the first week that we could talk about
it and then the next week I came back
after having played about 15 plus hours
of the game and I just had like all of
this like angst about it I was just I
was sad we literally named the video The
Last of Us - made me angry because it
did like there were so many moments that
made me angry and I think a lot of
people misinterpreted that as I didn't
like the game and I thought the game was
bad and I'm like no man like I obviously
I have like a couple issues with the
game which we're going to talk about in
our spoiler cast but I think the game is
phenomenal and
variety of ways the the idea that a game
at all can make you feel anything is a
testament to the work that they did
narrative lis and I think we all agree
that Naughty Dog is one of the standouts
in the video game industry of doing
really impactful narrative work that
makes people have feelings about things
because there's a lot of games that
don't I mean they may build a really
cool narrative but it doesn't
necessarily make you feel anything it
was like that was cool and that was it
you know and you move on with your life
yeah definitely not one of those games
where you just like brush it off and
you're like I was a nice trip okay cool
whatever
now this is definitely this was a game
that I talked about in the show I
journaled my way through it because I I
mean I first of all didn't really have
anyone to talk to because I was playing
it before and then also because I just
felt like I needed to process what was
going on or what my thoughts were during
it and that really helped me to where at
the end I didn't really feel any
confusion I kind of knew exactly how I
felt but I also after talking with other
folks who had finished the game realized
that I had taken a much more optimistic
spin on some of the things that happened
whereas they did not like I can
understand why that would maybe make you
have different feelings about the game
in general so so yeah I mean I this was
by but by far this is my game of the
year and will be a difficult one to
unseat simply because of the way it made
me feel on the way it impacted me and I
think that that's just something that's
fairly rare in games and that's not to
say that there won't be incredible games
coming out later this fall but it's hard
for me to imagine having a similar
experience like I had with this game
with anything else a couple days ago so
I'm still in that processing mode and
the callee sounds like you've been
thinking about it for like a week or you
were thinking about it like four weeks
straight and I find myself just sitting
here and all these ideas are popping in
my head like what is the symbolism of
this and what could this mean and what
could that mean was this action
justified why and I like you know you
keep saying as well it made me feel and
it's still making me feel and so then I
find myself going down this rabbit hole
and I hop on my phone look at the
internet look at all these theories and
then I saw myself getting depressed and
it's just like this cycle of like I got
it just like let my brain do its own
thing on its own but something
interesting is I finished the game and I
had to finish well when I started this
past weekend I had only maybe like 10
hours into the game so I played about 20
hours over the course of two days so I
didn't get to you know like stop every
few hours and whatnot which actually I
would say I I was never so disturbed
that I need I felt the need to stop
which just I'm something I'm excited to
talk about during Nia's foiler cast
because it sounds like that's that was a
common thing that a lot of people had
but after you play it and then you hop
into you let's say like another game you
really realize how well done how well
polished and we'll executed that the
last of us part two really is because I
started playing another game and I
talked about I'm playing ghost of
Tsushima that's not this game I'm not
referring to this game and it was like
man this this feels like a video game
like this feels gamy and I know some
games go for that route but it was
really an eye-opener
you know how well and immersed in
cinematic those Naughty Dog games really
are and yeah I'm just writing this is
the first time I've talked about this
game out loud so I'm Bradley so I'm
gonna stop right now but I'm processing
all of my feelings and emotions live
live no that's that's good I think like
that's that is what this game is really
kind of instilled in the community is
this sense of discussion and this sense
of you know let's talk about how this
game made us feel and unfortunately
there are some very divisive opinions
out there and you know I myself included
really struggled to verbalize how I felt
about this game in the beginning and I
think taking some time to process is has
been very good for me but there are
still some things that I just you know
don't like about some choices that were
made but it doesn't mean that you know
now your dog is a is a terrible
developer for making those choices and I
like I'm finger wagging at them it's
like no it just like it's okay that I
didn't like those choices there are some
things narrative lis that I struggle to
understand and it's not again that
abstract thinking of symbol is
it's more of was this a right choice for
the game does this make sense you know
when I play something like this
especially I came like this like I said
I really try to put myself in that
person's shoes that characters shoes and
get where they're coming from and I
think for that reason I'm able to avoid
a lot of the stresses of some of
particular actions like okay if I'm them
and this is my motivation this makes
sense I'm doing this but there were some
choices and some actions by certain
characters I didn't quite understand and
and I wrote it all down I did a journal
like Samer but I did chicken scratch a
lot of stuff so I was struggling to
process it so I was writing all these
things down and I was like okay I still
couldn't come to a conclusion I even try
to like write it all out and I couldn't
so again excited to talk to you guys
later about it but yeah there are a few
things I don't quite think we're
necessary or needed in this game but
we're still in there but that said still
one of the best games I think I've ever
played
it's yeah I know we've talked a lot
about the story but something that they
also did really excellently with this
game which absolutely sets it as a game
of the Year contender is the
world-building environmental
storytelling and atmosphere building
that's something that the last of us the
original game also did very well and I
think they took it even a step further
here and I can vividly remember like
specific scenes where I would just sit
in cover for like minutes at a time like
trying to figure out how I'm going to
get through this level because I know
that if I make one wrong move like all
of these clickers are gonna descend on
anok and I'm gonna die a gruesome death
instead very few games really accomplish
that kind of stealth gameplay so
excellently as we see in the Last of Us
part two and I want to give a shout out
here to our friend Steve Saylor the
blind gamer who came on what's good
games live to talk about the
accessibility options that are in the
game that really allow many different
types of gamers to experience the
stealth gameplay that maybe haven't
before because stealth games are
traditionally very brutal and very
difficult and by definition unaccessible
and I think that Naughty Dog absolutely
deserves accolades for the work they did
to take this really phenomenal stealth
gameplay that they've created and make
it so that as
any gamers as possible could play it the
the accessibility was the first thing I
looked at actually because when I
started game I always like to enable
subtitles I have a really difficult time
following the stories of games if I
don't have subtitles and I've watched a
lot of TV with subtitles um so that was
like the first thing I did because I
wanted to be able to pay attention and
and really take in everything that was
happening and so I just spent just like
five minutes digging through the menus
and I was so impressed and like and you
know the stuff that you don't think of
as accessibility like motion sickness
options I have a friend who I my old
roommate who played through the Last of
Us a couple years ago and she has really
bad motion sickness and it was such a
struggle and like I literally tell
people like she loved it so much she
dry-heave turns way through that game
and it was a it was a lot a the first
she was the first person I texted when I
saw those accessibility options I was
like there is a whole motion sickness
thing like you'll actually be able to
play this game without taking Dramamine
like you're gonna you're gonna love it
and it absolutely deserves accolades for
that I think that's something that's
kind of getting overlooked in the
discourse around this game because
there's a lot there's a lot being made
about you know killing docks or the
level of violence or whatever it is but
we really can't overlook that because I
think it's a standard that a lot of at
least Triple A games should be able to
hit and should should emulate so I
absolutely agree it deserves much more
than just a tip of the hat for I mean
I'm almost willing to overlook my
grievances with some of the plot choices
this point that this could also
potentially be a game that will be hard
to unseat esta Merced because of what
they've done with accessibility and how
they've innovated and pushed forward
because when we talk about Game of the
Year in our discussions one of the
things that I always hammer home for my
personal feelings about games that I
look at as Game of the Year contenders
are things that are pushing the envelope
whether it be with story with animation
with gameplay and I think that Naughty
Dog kind of like hit
a bunch of those check marks with what
they did with the Last of Us part two
and the fact that I didn't appreciate
certain story choices does not take away
from the innovation that they did have
with this game and the phenomenal work
that the development team did in
building this game absolutely I also
just want to give a little bit of a
shout out to the combat because like for
the the footage we see we've been seeing
I was so impressed when I first saw at
e3 a couple years ago like how fluid
Ellie's animations look and how it
almost looks like scripted sequences and
I think because you're you're if you get
caught right like I you play a lot of
stuff but you spotted or heard you have
to do a lot of running and maneuvering
to get out of those sticky situations
and the way that is animated makes it so
like harrowing and tense and it's it's
just beautifully executed I think yeah
there was that one chase sequence I'm
like nope Yeah right go ahead Britney oh
no I was gonna say I also liked all the
different items that your disposal with
the combat you know if you want to try
to be sneaky squirrel like here's the
thing as I suck at stealth
so I was talking about this that I
turned on the go invisible while stealth
or while prone yeah promo so I if I got
caught I could just go into prone and I
was like okay this is gonna help me get
through the game in the weekend but when
I try to be big brave girl and not use
that I would like I'd like to think of
different ways I can [ __ ] him all up
right so I liked always having that
glass bottle and if I was I would throw
that down and then I would pull no first
I lay down one of those traps mines
those little whatever I think they're
called trap the wire mines and whatever
lay one of those down you threw a bottle
everyone comes rushing and then they
just all like explode and then behind
you saying then I'll quickly switch to
my shotgun because I know I'm gonna be
getting bum-rushed by who knows what
then and then I have my Molotov over
here and so I really liked how there was
just so many different ways you could
approach a crowd and that was really fun
too oh yeah I love I love getting them
together I don't do the tripmine I just
do the Molotov so like all the before
this is really only works for clickers
or infected but yeah noise maker over
there Molotov watch them all burn decent
popcorn
go on enemies would burn and then they
would stop burning and then they would
just start walking around so I lost
faith in the mall top I'm like that's
not yeah sometimes you guys depends on
where they are on the periphery of the
fire running towards you wasn't
horrifying enough an on fire clicker run
really fun moments of gameplay that you
know we're really harrowing for sure and
I think that that gameplay really shines
a lot in the more exploratory moments of
the game and that's something that I
really appreciated that they opened up
this time around because there was
obviously a few of those moments in the
Last of Us but nothing compared to how
much you can explore in the last most
part - and I just really enjoyed some
quiet moments that you could just
completely miss if you didn't take the
time to fully explore some of these
buildings and things that were you know
intentionally placed in the world and I
really think that a lot of games
struggle to find the balance between
wanting to encourage exploration but
also rewarding that exploration and
that's something that this game did very
well and we obviously they were you are
gonna find something around every corner
and I certainly opened plenty of drawers
with nothing in them but just like my
life but overall I think that a lot of
the exploration felt worth it especially
when you would open a building and you
would see like a hole in the floor and
you're like oh no do I want to go this
way I actually had one of that moment I
was like do I want to do this right now
go back outside real quick or like
another lapper on the neighborhood so
dang satisfying that's a simple thing
but it made me feel so good is breaking
the glass on these buildings yes there's
a whole Twitter thread dedicated to how
that was all animated and the sound was
recorded and I'll find it in retweet on
my channel but
the idea of like here's this building
you know a lot of games like here's the
golden you can't go in it because
there's glass windows and you're like yo
I could I could in theory smash that war
if like the bar is her place just hot
like wide enough where you know you
could squeeze through this game lets you
traverse all of that so finding the
glass building like okay that's a
building I can go in and being able to
break that in it did kind of give you
that sense of like I'm not supposed to
be in here but I am what good news am I
gonna find and it was those often often
times in those moments that you would
find the notes find me collectibles that
would give you some backstory on the
building that you just had explored and
that was really special to you and I
think that was so integral to the world
building yeah I definitely had
thankfully was very early on in the game
where I was like oh man yeah this
building I guess I can't get in there
and then I just stared and looked at
that glass for a minute and I think yes
we can okay brick got in there it was
like haha
I have outsmarted you game although this
is what you loot Lee I mean I think we
could keep going and going about like
some of these really fantastic moments
but I think you know to kind of wrap up
our our discussion on some games that
were really impactful for us
Kali do you have any final thoughts
either about the Last of Us part 2 being
a game of your contender or any of the
other titles that we've seen so far this
year I you know it's last position is
such a difficult one because it is very
complex
like there's a lot to unpack this game
and I think that's fascinating and
valuable and so I definitely think it's
a contender for me and it's so weird to
compare that to something like Animal
Crossing which is just an entirely
different it doesn't even feel like
they're in the same medium they are so
different that's gonna be the trickiest
thing because I think it comes down to
like what is a game of the year for you
is it something that captures is it is
it something that's kind of a phenomenon
is it something that sparks discussion
it's obviously a very personal decision
and it's you know I've started a second
playthrough The Last of Us and I think
that's going to really make or break
at Game of the Year status for me I I
loved it
more on the when I started the second
playthrough I appreciated the little
things a lot more I wasn't like
constantly nervous about who was gonna
die so I was like actually appreciating
some of the the mechanical design
decisions so I think when I get through
my my second playthrough way I think
I'll have a better idea
excellent
it's timer watched me play some parts of
the game and I was being very reserved
and she's like yep you'll be fine here
you don't have to be scared I was like
dude do you want me do you want me to
tell you whether or not it was like yes
tell us she was like yes it was like
okay you can chill okay I was like you
have it go you're coming up in like five
to ten minutes boyfriend did that for me
for Resident Evil 2 remake like okay you
can use some more ammo you're okay oh
yeah yeah what a hundred percent timer
do you have any final thoughts about
game of the year so far uh no I think
it's a kind of very touched on it like I
do think and I think to Callie's pointed
it it really depends on what you as a
person really look for in your game of
the air but I do think for me personally
it's gonna be hard to surpass the last
West part to not to say that other games
won't do other parts better than that
game but I think emotionally wise and
like just because there's so many layers
to to dig into of that game and
instamatics and all that fun stuff I
honestly kind of felt like I was taking
a college course afterwards where I was
like trying to dissect all of the things
but I really liked that aspect but I can
definitely see how that is not something
that anybody would always want from
their game they might be like no no my
game of the year is like something
that's a little bit more chills or
something like Animal Crossing although
there's a lot of layers to that too so
yeah I just think it'll depend but for
me it's probably going to be the Last of
Us I think the other one that is
upcoming that it has potential is like
cyberpunk
oh yes Brittany
yeah I'm still unpacking I'm still you
know I need a probably a good another
week before I'm fully like okay
I think I understand how I feel about
this game but like I said earlier I
think in terms of quality t loo to you
is one of the best games I've ever
played it's now more about me processing
like what's the story means to me how
does the story speak to me how do I feel
about the direction this game went in
but yeah I mean I'm kind of it's time
we're at this point between although it
sounds like stammers more leaning toward
t2 I'm kind of joking right now between
fantasy 7t Lou - I think cyberpunk is
gonna be right up there as well yeah it
is a lot in with the delay for cyberpunk
I think that that is inherently going to
impact its ability to win hearts and
minds for game of the year for 2020
because I think people aren't just just
aren't gonna get enough time to value
that game before a lot of the voting
discussions have to take place before
the end of the year and that is to me a
little tragic but I don't think CD
Projekt RED is going to suffer any if
they don't win game of the year for 2020
it just means they'll have probably a
few less trophies on their shelf but um
I think have to build some more anyway
it's fine but I think that there's you
know a lot of interesting games to come
that could potentially be contenders I
know Assassin's Creed Valhalla is
certainly up there as one of my more
anticipated games for the fall and I
think that you know there's games that I
think will surprise us - you know like
but I mean I think everyone knows that
the cyberpunk is really like the
de-facto big contender to t Liu right
now
and the rest of the games are kind of
like hey maybe there's a dark horse out
there and maybe someone watching in chat
has a dark horse nomination that they'd
like us to to discuss in the Q&A so
thank you everybody like a dragon of
course but thank you everybody for
checking out our games of the year so
far discussion now we're going to check
in once again on all of the donations
that have been happening
for these fantastic charities that were
raising money for today with our friends
at GameSpot and then you know give you
guys a couple of minutes to if you have
questions for us either about game of
the user far above anything else for
that matter
you can drop those in the chat and we
will try to get to as many as we can
so Callie where are we at with some
donations we've we've gotten small
donation I'm really excited because we
have some friends in the donation list
here we have the wonderful Steve Saylor
with a $25 donations he lives matter
thank you Steve
we're actually gonna have Steve on again
after dark this week also so it's a bang
and of this whole production and then we
have a $25 donation to black lives
matter from Alejandro filari our very
own editor here at King spot what's up
we've known Alessandra for so many years
and he's like one of the few people that
I run into at what it feels like at
every single free event that I go to and
now that we aren't going to events
anymore I feel like I seen you in
forever Alessandra but he's lovely and
I'm glad I get to shout out his Resident
Evil reviews show and if he was wanted
to thing out his work and in Callie's
work don't forget gates are calm is
where you can find all of their writings
and musings and and videos and articles
and all kinds of other great coverage
you guys have a pretty deep bench of
people writing for you these days I do
we are you know we have I think a
smaller team than you might expect but
we really do a lot and I really do love
the team that we have so I'm always
excited to a shout people out on the
show but also just to work every day oh
thank you for the shout out
oh poor is I think you guys work hard
you deserve you deserve the accolades
and then speaking of games my employees
over on the Direct Relief donation page
we have one from our own Richie Breck
amante for $20 he says know why I've
held out this long I'm playing Last of
Us - but you ladies got me hyped to play
it downloading it this weekend for sure
and Richie and then again from Steve
Saylor $20 to direct relief they all
love you all very much
he's--oh much a nice guy that Steve
Saylor he just a wonderful human being
mmm Oh once again thank you to everybody
who donated I know we still have a
little bit of time left and we're gonna
be doing the Q&A but we really do
appreciate just anything that anyone can
spare and just you know running the word
that we are doing some charity stuff
here at GameSpot so we really appreciate
everyone who tuned in yes
ditto what she said I'm and I was told
that you have some questions and I know
we don't probably don't have like I've
been watching the chats I know that a
lot of people were kind of focused on
some of their own discussions as they
were having and so if you guys do have
questions you can keep dropping them in
the chat we do have eyes on both of us
good games channel chat and of course
the GameSpot channel chat as well but
you have a couple questions yes do I
have I have a handful of questions from
the mostly the YouTube traffic that chat
a couple from twitch first one is from
Charles Washington on YouTube here's a
question does halo if they knock it out
of the park have a goatee chance
I think Britney and I are the big Halo
fans here at wgg this is definitely one
of those Dark Horse contenders for sure
I think the fact that we haven't seen
anything about halo Infinite is either
really bad or really good I don't think
it's gonna little yeah McCoy will figure
it out later
so much riding on this game you know I
think a lot of folks weren't super
pleased with Halo 5 I didn't mind it
personally it wasn't my favorite by any
means but this is going to be a title
that we're assuming we know is gonna
launch on Xbox series X and there's just
so much riding on this that I'm really
really anxious to see of you know I'm
hoping it's leaning forward that really
really good like Andrews
hope they're holding all of their cards
to their chest but it's about time you
started letting those cards fly to the
wind sorry people because we don't have
that much time left I could see a
reasoning behind not doing it only
because and I'm not trying to diminish
the game well right now I prayed but
more of like I feel like if you know you
like halo you probably don't need a lot
to sell you on it therefore they're PR
beats leading ups which does it doesn't
need to be like a year-long campaign for
this game because you kind of know in a
certain sense what you're gonna get and
if they have anything like super new or
exciting maybe they want you to just
play it and like go forth and see well
I'm trying to be optimistic here I
definitely thought thank you I
appreciate that listen from our resident
salty host but I think that in my mind I
the reason why I was a little concerned
about it was because I think this is an
amazing golden opportunity for Xbox PR
marketing and to recapture people who
were really big into Halo in previous
generations and maybe have been away
from Halo for a long time maybe they
just stopped playing shooters maybe they
got busy with life and stop playing
games overall and now with us all being
home and not traveling as much and
people playing more games than they
probably ever have before
that there's an opportunity to say hey
did you used to love halo did you have a
great no time playing with your friends
or do you have memories of experiencing
Master Chief's story but we want to
bring you back into the fold and I
appreciate what you said about you know
there are always gonna be those die
hearts that are gonna pick this up and
get their series X on day one no matter
what I don't think those are the people
that Xbox needs to sell I think they
need to sell the people who are like you
know v was just okay yeah the
multiplayer did some really cool things
and was successful but this campaign was
like I don't really know and I just feel
like Halo hasn't had like a giant win in
a long time I feel like if we don't see
anything decent at their upcoming
showcase like first party showcase then
that's what I'll worry yeah I mean
I understand also like with both of you
you're saying it's like well if you're
gonna halo is halo-halo carries a lot of
weight but like Andreo saying to you
know the people who maybe we're into
halo a couple years back maybe around
halo 3 halo
maybe he'll a1 through halo 3 and they
dropped off around halo 4 and 5 you know
there are a lot more shooters on the
market now and if someone just enjoyed
halo primarily for the shooting
mechanics or whatnot that market is so
much more saturated now so if you do
have something really cool and exciting
that's gonna reanimate I mean that's
kind of dramatic buzzword but do
something cool with this genre like you
guys start promoting it because I think
that you got to build that hype for
those people to recapture them you gotta
let people save money to buy that
expensive new console war first pretty
thing as soon yes it's sometime in July
yeah woman confirmed a date yet how they
don't like July yeah I'm definitely one
of the people that needs to get sold on
the series X more so than halo but I I
didn't if you're gonna mark it
specifically to me Microsoft if you're
listening I would say you just have to
like retcon everything you did to
Cortana in five and then fix Cortana and
then be a hundred person on board with
Halo infinite like I'm hope yeah yeah
one of those people I think that's what
kind of left me with a sour taste in my
mouth was everything that went down with
that whole part of the storyline and I'm
hoping that 3 / 3 can bring it back
exactly exactly
well thank you for your question so much
I will move on to the next one
Charles Washington thank you no I'm
going to go back to the second one and
because it's in the question is actually
about Series X so that makes a lot more
sense of what we just talked about this
is from Dovahkiin II Scrolls on YouTube
excellent
top tier name do you think of Xbox
series S or I think it means I think
they mean X Y s or Lockhart
oh they're talking about the digital oh
yeah oh yeah so there was a that that
rumored like photo that was going around
right of what it looks like the little
minis and I I mean I think the form
factor of that little mini one looks
great I think that it's smart of them to
make it smaller
PlayStation if it's gonna be all digital
it's like why make it so big and have it
take up so much real estate on your home
entertainment system I think that
digital is a wave coming that you cannot
escape and as a physical collector
Britain and I talk all the time about
our physical collections like I'm sad
that I had to like abandon my physical
collection of games but we all knew it
was going to happen eventually and
apparently this is the generation I
still don't think the rest of the world
is ready for that when I say that I mean
like the telecommunications industry I
mean like the hard drive manufacturers
and a variety of X factors that are not
the console makers that make it
challenging for a large number of gamers
to assimilate to an all digital future
as a minute rule the one minimalist of
the group I welcome our digital future
please come to me I want no stuff in my
house right now where we can start
testing that and I think that's it's
exciting but also kind of in but it's ok
like I also have too much [ __ ] in my
house like I don't need anymore it's
fine
but yeah we're it's interesting that
we're finally in a spot where I feel
like we can test out these old digital
consoles and test out this all digital
future like Andrea is saying I think
we're a ways way ways off before that's
all you're gonna get offered or just
digital only that's not gonna work but
it's gonna be fascinating I hope we get
the data to see what the breakdown is
between who buys physical who buys
digital because I'd be very curious to
find out well it's over 50% now as far
as the digital edition versus then yeah
so I mean I've already put my flag down
that I'm getting the disc version
because I still enjoy watching blu-rays
and I'm glad that both of the consoles
are gonna be doing 4k blu-rays I think
now with this generation 4k TVs are
much more prevalent I didn't upgrade my
HGTV to a 4k TV until Xbox 1x was was
released even though both of the
previous consoles weren't capable of
doing 4k and it's because like 4k TVs
for the longest time we're still just
too expensive and 4k gaming monitors for
PCs are still very expensive but at
least the price of 4k televisions feels
it gets come down a little bit so it's
more approachable and I think that that
to me as a gamer is so important so I'm
gonna I'm team disc still disclosed yeah
I do not have a single disc in my house
wish I could live like that yeah I want
to be discus but I I'm afraid of the
inevitability of getting a physical copy
of a game we mostly get codes now we
mostly get digital copies of games for
like reviews generally I'll get a
physical copy and that's when I don't
want to be locked out of a review
because the way that games are
distributed so I feel like I'll have to
do disc version but I would ideally do
the digital version I think in all my
years covering games I've only received
two or three physical copies of stuff
Brewery yeah it's all codes I mean
granted like it's I've only been getting
game reviews for maybe like five years
now or not but yeah
craziness Nintendo sometimes since
physical copies but that's totally
separate obviously from this discussion
and I I feel like it's really dwindling
like maybe you'll get a debug disc in
which case you need a whole other
console anyway so they'll just bite the
bullet and go digital yeah and
thankfully debugs have kind of been a
little obsolete in the digital future
that we've been going to which has been
nice me I recently talked to somebody on
a PR team about if we had a debug which
we do not because we don't do nearly the
amount of coverage that you guys at
GameSpot do it comes to like capture and
guides and walkthroughs and all that so
we just don't really have a need to have
a debug
for people-watching what we mean by that
is we mean a developer kit for the
console so this is essentially a special
type of console that developers use to
design games and very few let me
emphasize very very few gaming outlets
get access to these debug consoles from
the console makers themselves because
you just don't really need to have this
really expensive piece of machinery the
regular consoles typically work fine but
especially now yeah exactly
like back in my day I definitely
absolutely
they've done a review on a debug unit
but it's been a while I feel like that
was that was on a ps3 debug I think so I
would say I haven't maybe I'm just being
too neurotic about my holding onto the
disks maybe I should just accept the
inevitability of the future it was hard
for me to girls when I got there and now
I yeah every time I have to buy some big
physical I still get the collector's
editions because like I like to display
them but as far as the games go and like
I can't do it yeah I mean I still have
all about the collector's editions with
toys and stuff like I think I don't know
if I'm ever gonna outgrow that obviously
like my collection of tchotchkes is
nothing compared to Brittany's very
intense collection which you can see
just a sliver of behind her that's just
a fraction of her collection Kalia
she is rooms whole rooms of her house
full of stuff
I love that that's I love that never
change thank you thank you my dear
awarder I mean very organized hoarder I
mean listen I don't have pathways all of
my hallways are open there's it's all
good but yeah I know but it's the
reality of like I'd like the collector's
editions that I can't buy anymore things
I just can't and it took me a long time
to get around to that but I'm there now
I'm sure once Dragon Age for collectors
edition is announced you'll be changing
ya know it oh no I'm still buying
collector's edition slidey I die there's
no doubt about that but like physical
goods and whatnot I'm trying to be a
really good girl and stay away and not
do it I'm trying good for you like my
pop will just be full of statues my bed
will become a bunch of different
statutes just surrounded by all the
collectors edition things that's a very
intense parent to wake up to I know
right especially like you just see
Kratos judging you
he's like be better you're like oh no
I'm sorry got seven hours of sleep last
night to be better yet have one more
question yes I I did want to say I would
definitely love garol more Geralt
statues to wake up to but that's just me
oh yeah we'll do one more question let
me see wanna make sure I pick like a
really really good one I guess this kind
of fits the the discussion that we had
this is from Jacob McCourt on YouTube I
may have missed at the beginning of the
discussion but are there any indie games
that you haven't spoken about that are
on your radar for game of the year um
pretty with ear sorry
like that wrong oh yeah this is a tough
one because we haven't gotten as much
time to do indie games as you would
think knowing that we're not traveling
because a lot of the games that I've
seen so far for 2020 that I'm interested
in aren't out yet
I mean bugs that game coming up holiday
tour why they said um did any of you
play murder by numbers the pick Ross
murder mystery game I've heard about
this have it yet it's I really like it
it's real
cute it's like a strong like Indy
contender for me like I said at the
beginning of the show my game of the
year last year was disco Elysium which
was one that like was a complete dark
horse for me and so I'm always excited
to check out smaller games and Indies
like that but I would definitely
recommend if you're in to pick cross at
all murder by numbers is super cute like
just it it's so much more than I
expected it to be the premise is just
pick Ross game but it's a murder mystery
set in the nineties but it's it's more
than that um I definitely wanted to get
that game a shout out it's yeah yeah I
like perusing the market looking at
these fun little indie games my problem
is I spent a good solid month and a half
or two months playing all that you could
see games back to back and that was at a
time when I probably when I would have
had a lot more time to check out the
indie games but I feel like what the
games we've been getting recently
they've been pretty beefy the review
copies of the games new playing Final
Fantasy 7 was beefy to lose to is beefy
what else was there are e3 and I was
unfortunately not very beefy at all
having the time to play these games has
been has been difficult yeah I can it
despite the fact that we're home all the
time now I think that's a really good
point to bring up to you is because I'm
thinking about it usually I play a good
handful dozens of indie games every year
so I really enjoy them especially for
co-op experience there's some real gems
in there but yeah it's with everything
going on and I was talking to andrey
about this earlier you think since we're
home all the time we have all the time
in the world to play new games and dive
into new experiences and it's like
actually i mean obviously there's life
stuff going on on the side but it's just
been really busy too with everything
going on now the III last 13 months you
know could never ending the summer of
gaming make it stop but just
exponentially increased yeah exactly
it's just like it's been it's been
challenging for sure I mean in just less
it what's good I know that a lot of
outlets are doing more content than we
would have done normally because we're
we don't have to travel and so we're
just or streaming more we have two
episodes of the show now I mean there's
certainly games that I'm looking forward
to but I'm sorry I don't have a better
answer for your question I just haven't
spent as much time
with Indies this year as I normally do
but definitely looking forward to its
whenever that game comes out I'm so
excited for you blitz it looks so good
cannot wait the reason I chose this
question is just because I always want
to remind myself that like the game of
the year can go beyond triple-a and I
guess I hadn't thought about it until I
asked the question from Jacob McCourt I
you know I haven't really dedicated as
much time as I going really good to
Indies and that's something I kind of
want to rectify although if I can give
game of the year to the Yakuza camera
Clubman game I would do that
love the cavalry company I knew I liked
you Cali but like it just went up a
whole new level baby girl he loves that
mini game on the show last week the
whole thing I want a whole 40 hour
experience that I hated just to that all
he remembers all the hand signals let's
go
I would pay full $60 for that and I'll
pay the $20 DLC add-on I don't care
I'm sure yeah well I guess I'll have you
back on the show to talk about more yeah
cuz I in the future dragon we can talk
about that I'm so excited
those people that are your people with
Yakuza oh yeah I'm joining the fan club
I'm late to the party but I'm here now
[ __ ] let's go this spot has a whole
group of Gaza fans and they call
themselves the crime boys they they like
originated it's like this group of us
we're all like let's talk about Yosa
it's a think we have a huge job as I
continue to as what I'm trying to say so
hey come come to us join the crime boys
is what she's trying to join the crime
boys well Kelly this has been such a
delight to chat with you and
it's been so wonderful to work with
GameSpot again to help raise money and I
know that you know we didn't do game
play which is what some people were
hoping for but I think that this
conversation is a fun one to have as
well and kind of think about what we've
played so far this year and hear from
you about your thoughts as well and kind
of give us all like a reminder that yeah
there's some games that I missed that I
should maybe go spend some more time
with so thank you so much for having us
and thank you to everybody who took the
time to donate don't forget these
charities are still accepting donations
you guys are going to be doing this
stream for a few more weeks till yeah I
just echo that thank you guys for having
me I had a really great time talking
about this and I definitely play Final
Fantasy 7 remake and the charity links
will be open for a couple more weeks so
see the links obviously right here
they're pretty short easy to remember so
if you want to keep donating you can
absolutely do that tomorrow we will have
Mary Kish at 1 p.m. Pt a stream where
you love Mary so that's what's going on
tomorrow thank you again to everyone who
asked questions I'm sorry we couldn't
get to everyone's questions and thank
you all for donating see you tomorrow
bye everybody
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]